One question is how are happiness and habits
related?
And I’ve been researching and writing and
thinking and talking to people about happiness
for years.
And what I started to notice was that habits
play a really important role in happiness.
Because a lot of times when I would talk to
people there was some big happiness challenge
in their life that I realize was actually
related to some core habit.
And it wasn’t that they didn’t think or
know that if they got more sleep they’d
feel better or that if they didn’t spend
so much time on the Internet during work they’d
be more productive, or whatever.
They had identified the change that they wanted
to make but for some reason they weren’t
able to stick to that change.
They weren’t able to make that change happen
no matter how much they wanted to.
They could see that there was a happiness
gain out there but they weren’t able to
translate it into action.
And that got me very focused on the issue
of habit change.
So how is it that we specifically change a
habit so that we can make these desires, these
aims that are so pressing in our lives – how
can we translate it into real action, real
change in our everyday lives.
Because the fact is, you know, for most of
us there’s a lot of low hanging fruit.
There’s a lot of things – just part of
our ordinary day – things that don’t take
a lot of time, energy or money that if we
could do them they would make us happier.
Well we really have to get ourselves to actually
follow through.
And so that’s where habits come into play
because habits are the thing that allow you
to make those changes and just put them on
automatic pilot.
They’re just part of your everyday life
and they make you happier.